Nous étions excités par ces résultats, lorsque Jim se leva,
et là, ce fut vraiment remarquable.
Toute la biomécanique naturelle traitée par le système nerveux central
apparut dans le membre synthétique
comme un acte involontaire et automatique.
Toutes les subtilités du placement de pied lors d'une montée de marches –
(Applaudissements)
apparurent devant nos yeux.
Ici, la descente de Jim,
ses doigts bioniques approchant la prochaine marche,
faisant preuve de mouvements naturels
automatiquement, sans efforts.
Comme le système nerveux central de Jim reçoit les signaux proprioceptiques,
il sait contrôler le membre synthétique de façon naturelle.
Jim bouge et se comporte comme si le membre synthétique lui appartenait.
Par exemple, un jour au labo,
il marcha par erreur sur un rouleau de ruban adhésif.
Que fait-on dans ce cas-là ?
On ne se baisse pas comme ça ; c’est trop gênant.
On le secoue.
C’est exactement ce que fit Jim
seulement quelques heures après avoir été connecté.
Le plus intéressant pour moi,
c'est quand Jim nous raconta son expérience.
Il dit : « Le robot fait partie de moi. »
Jim Ewing : Le lendemain de ma première connexion au robot,
ma fille descendit et me demanda ce que ça fait d’être un cyborg.
Ma réponse fut que je ne me sentais pas cyborg.
J’avais l’impression d’avoir ma jambe
et que je n’étais pas attaché au robot
autant qu’il n’était attaché à moi
et qu’il faisait partie de moi.
C’est vite devenu ma jambe.
Hugh Herr : Merci.
(Applaudissements)
En connectant le système nerveux de Jim,
de façon bidirectionnelle, à son membre synthétique,
on obtint l’incarnation neurologique.
J’ai postulé que parce que Jim peut penser et bouger son membre synthétique,
et parce qu’il ressent ces mouvements dans son propre système nerveux,
la prothèse n’est plus un outil distinct,
mais fait partie intégrante du corps de Jim.
Grâce à l’incarnation neurologique, Jim ne se sent pas cyborg.
Il sent simplement qu’il a retrouvé
ses jambes, son corps.
On me demande souvent
quand je vais me faire relier à mes membres de manière bidirectionnelle,
quand je vais devenir un cyborg.
J’hésite à devenir un cyborg.
Avant mon amputation, j’étais un élève nul.
J’avais des notes terribles à l’école.
Mais après mon amputation,
je suis devenu professeur à MIT.
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
J’ai peur que si je reconnecte mes neurones à mes membres,
mon cerveau va retrouver sa forme moins intelligente.
(Rires)
Mais bon, ça va, je suis déjà titularisé au MIT.
(Applaudissements)
Je crois que la portée du design NeuroIncarné
s’étendra bien au-delà du remplacement de membres
et entrainera l’humanité dans des contrées
qui redéfiniront complètement le potentiel humain.
Au 21e siècle,
on prolongera le système nerveux dans de puissants exosquelettes
que les humains pourront contrôler et sentir avec leur cerveau.
Les muscles du corps pourront être reconfigurés
pour contrôler des moteurs puissants
et pour sentir les mouvements de l’exosquelette,
ce qui augmentera notre force, l’amplitude de nos sauts et notre vitesse.
Au 21e siècle, je crois que les humains deviendront des super-héros.
On pourra aussi prolonger nos corps
dans des structures non-anthropomorphes, comme des ailes,
contrôlant et sentant chaque mouvement dans notre système nerveux.
Léonard de Vinci a dit : « Quiconque aura goûté au vol
marchera à jamais les yeux tournés vers le ciel,
car là il a été, et là toujours il désirera ardemment retourner. »
Au crépuscule de ce siècle,
les humains seront méconnaissables,
de par leur morphologie et leur mouvement.
L’humanité va prendre son envol.
Jim Ewing chuta, il fut brisé,
mais ses yeux se tournèrent vers le ciel, là où il rêvait de retourner.
Après son accident, il rêvait de marcher
et de retrouver son sport favori : l’escalade.
Au MIT, Team Cyborg a construit pour Jim un membre adapté au monde vertical,
une jambe contrôlée par le cerveau, avec une gamme complète de sensations.
Armé de cette technologie, Jim regagna les Îles Caïman,
le site de son accident,
rebâti en cyborg, pour grimper de nouveau vers le ciel.
(Fracas de vagues)
(Applaudissements)
Merci.
Mesdames et messieurs, Jim Ewing, le premier grimpeur cyborg.
(Applaudissements)